Prof: All right.
Let us begin,
please.
We're going to get started to
stay on track for this morning.
Don't forget,
of course, that we have this
exciting event next Tuesday,
which is our second test.
There will be--I know.
Curb your enthusiasm.
There will be a review section
for that, indeed three of them,
next Monday night as we did
last time.
They'll be in room 207 of WLH
again this Monday:
seven, eight and nine
respectively,
and yours truly will be there.
We'll also have Monday
afternoon.
If you want individual help,
you can come to my office and
one of the TAs will be covering
a run of about four or five
hours there Monday afternoon
probably starting around one
o'clock,
and of course I'll be sending
you a prep sheet on this so that
you will know how to prepare for
this test just as we prepared
for the last test.
The test itself will be very
similar to the first test except
we--
when we get to the listening
pieces,
then we will not be so much
concentrating on individual
isolated aspects of melody,
rhythm and harmony but these
broader questions of form.
What is the form?
Where are we in the form?
That's the essence of the
assignment there.
We're working here with form
and it's very important.
It brings, I think--my guess is
in all of the listening that
you've been doing,
pop music, classical,
whatever it is,
how many when you were
listening ever thought about
form?
Did you ever think about it,
any of you?
Okay.
One person I see raised their
hand, and maybe Roger raises his
hand but not too
enthusiastically.
Yeah, it's the kind of thing
that you could do a lot of
playing and listening to music.
You could take as my
seventeen-year-old,
maybe seventeen-year-old,
maybe twelve,
thirteen years of cello and I
could ask him,
"What form do we have?
Where are we in the form?"
and he wouldn't really know
because he hasn't been exposed
to that sort of thing.
Well, it does help us.
It's a whole dimension of
listening that we can plug into,
whether it's pop music and
you're dealing with verse and
chorus and bridge.
or even as we'll see today,
ostinato--in pop music
or in classical music you plug
in the form.
Now what are the six forms that
we are going to be plugging in
here?
Hm?
Somebody run us through our
checklist.
Roger, get us started, please.
Student: --say one or--
Prof: Yeah,
you can say one and then you
might pass the baton.
>
Student: Sonata-allegro.
Prof: Okay.
Sonata-allegro,
the most difficult,
the biggest one.
We spent the most time with
that.
What else?
Chris.
Student: Fugue.
Prof: Fugue.
We spent a lot of time with
that, fairly difficult.
Daniel.
Student: Rondo.
Prof: Rondo,
a little bit easier in the
sense that you've got this one
theme that kind of bludgeons you
to--
if you get a theme and then you
get something else,
and that theme comes back and
then probably something else yet
again.
Then that theme comes back and
then something else again and
again,
and then theme and so on,
so you get the object and then
a lot of contrast but the object
keeps coming back.
What else?
Have we mentioned--Chelsea.
Student: Ternary.
Prof: I'm sorry.
Student: Ternary form.
Prof: Ternary form. Yeah.
That may be the easiest,
kind of just the A,
B, A idea.
And we're missing one, I think.
Yeah.
Student:
>
Prof: Theme and
variations.
Your name, please.
Student: Kristin.
Prof: I'm sorry?
Prof: Kristin. Okay.
Thanks very much, Kristin.
So theme and variations is the
last one.
When you go to a concert,
sometimes you can pick up the
program,
and here is a cover of a
program that's going to serve as
the make-up for our--
the make-up concert for our
class.
It's next Saturday--yes,
yeah, a week from Saturday.
The Jonathan Edwards Orchestra
is going to be performing at
Battell and they'll be doing the
Beethoven Eighth Symphony and
when you go there you're going
to have four movements in the
Beethoven Eighth Symphony.
What's a good guess as to what
form the first movement's going
to be in?
Student:
>
Prof: Sonata-allegro.
Okay.
Sonata-allegro.
The second movement-- Well,
it could be in a number of
different forms.
What's a good guess for what
the form of the third movement
will be?
Ternary form.
It's going to be some kind of
minuet or perhaps scherzo--I
think in this case scherzo,
trio, scherzo,
that idea.
Ternary form usually is the
third movement of these
four-movement symphony--
and then the last
movement--well,
we'll have to sort of come to
terms with that--
figure that one out on the fly,
and that's what we'll be doing
in our test on Tuesday,
although it will be a slow,
sort of lento fly there.
We'll be going through it much
more slowly than just one pass.
So sometimes when listening
you've got to hear the music and
make some kind of educated
determination as to what the
form is and then you kind,
as I say, drop this template of
that particular form down in
your mind and then filter the
music thereafter through that
model,
be it the model of
sonata-allegro or the model of
fugue or the model of rondo.
You kind of hear the piece in
that form thereafter.
Questions about that?
All right.
If not, let's proceed with one
final form today,
which is ostinato.
That's our sixth form.
We haven't been introduced to
that.
We're going to do
ostinato,
but before we get to that,
I want to recap one thing
having to do with theme and
variation form because it allows
us to bring in some other things
that we have been talking about.
So it's a good culminating
listening experience,
and that is the finale of
Beethoven's "Eroica
Symphony."
Anybody know what--why it's
called the "Eroica
Symphony"?
Who is the hero that's
referenced there?
Caroline.
Student: Napoleon.
Prof: Napoleon, right.
So Beethoven was working on
this symphony.
Napoleon was the hero.
Then he gets word from Paris
that Napoleon has had himself
crowned emperor.
He thinks: "Oh, my God,
Napoleon's just a tyrant like
all the rest of them,"
so he's furious and he
scratches out on his score--
and I--when you get to the
Beethoven chapter of your
textbook,
look there.
There's a photograph of the
cover of the "Eroica
Symphony"
and you can see the big hole
where Beethoven with his knife
scratched out Napoleon's name.
And then later on he goes on to
simply identify that as
"Symphony for a Hero,"
the "Eroica
Symphony."
So that's what we mean by that
particular--the hero originally
was to be Napoleon.
So when we finish this
exercise, when you finish this
course, you will have actually
been exposed to a number of
Beethoven's symphonies.
We're talking about No. 3 here.
We opened with No. 5.
On the concert a week from
Saturday,
you'll have Beethoven 8 and
those of you that went to the
preceding concert are not barred
from attending the one on the
first of November.
You too can get in the door
there, so you might want to go
to that--
7:30 in Battell Chapel
November^( )1st,
and the concert the other night
we had Beethoven's Sixth so you
will have been exposed to four
Beethoven symphonies here in
this course and that--
that's pretty good for a
beginning course,
great.
All right.
So let's talk about the finale
here and it's based on--and it's
kind of fun.
It's actually more complex than
we would ever do on a test but
it's fun to work through it.
It's based on two themes,
so this is a set of variations
using two themes.
Beethoven liked to do this.
He did this--actually,
he did this in a slow movement
of >.
What's that?
What symphony is that?
Anybody remember?
Yeah.
It was the Beethoven Sixth that
we had at the concert the other
night with the woodwinds and all
>
and so on.
That was the second theme.
That was kind of the second,
the B idea if you will,
of the two themes.
So there in the slow movement
of Beethoven's "Sixth
Symphony"
we had a double variation,
and what we mean by double
variation is simply that there
are two themes in play.
So here we have the two themes.
One, the way he's constructed
here, is in the treble.
>
That's theme number one.
Here is theme number two.
>
So those are the two themes.
So let's listen to some of this.
It's going to start out with
just a little bit of a curtain
raiser so I have a curtain
raiser and then one of the
themes will come in.
Which one does Beethoven start
with?
>
Okay. Up goes the curtain.
Repeat.
>
Continue.
Repeat.
Okay.
We're going to stop it there.
So which theme did he choose to
work with here at the outset?
Anybody know? Daniel?
Student: The bass theme.
Prof: Yeah,
the bass theme,
>
and how is it being played?
Wasn't it a pizzicato?
>
So that's the bass theme.
All right.
So that's in a sense--we'll
say--call it variation one.
Let's go on to variation two
here.
Which theme does he choose to
use at this point?
>
Repeat.
And repeat.
>
Okay.
So which theme is he using
there?
One or two?
Yeah.
Evgeny says two and it was
still the bass theme and it was
a little bit harder to hear this
time because it was being
covered up above by some
counterpoint.
So we've got the theme.
We've got counterpoint against
it.
Let's go on into variation
number three and we'll see what
happens.
>
Which one here?
Repeat, going on,
>
and repeat.
So which theme this time?
One or two?
Student: Two.
Prof: Still two,
but he's moved it up into the
first violins,
moved it up higher and he's got
more sort of fast-running
counterpoint against it.
Let's go on to the next.
We've got to get number one at
some point.
>
Hooray.
All right.
What was the solo instrument
there, and how did he
orchestrate this?
Well, the first statement of
this first theme,
he assigned it to a solo
instrument.
Then in the repeat he had the
strings take it over.
Then that solo instrument came
back and then on the repeat the
strings took it over again.
So it's an interesting use of
orchestration here.
Let's listen to this variation
again and what is the solo
instrument up on top?
>
Okay.
Let's pause it there just for a
second.
So what's the solo instrument?
Student: Oboe.
Prof: Oboe, yeah.
So there's an oboe penetrating
up on high.
Question up there, Roger?
Student: Can we think of
this kind of like the
>
Prof: Yeah.
I wouldn't want to take that
too far though.
This is sort of an isolated
event here where you do have a
call and a response.
And it does happen just in this
one variation but it's going to
be limited to this one
variation,
whereas in a Bessie Smith blues
tune you would have that call
and response idea carried on
throughout the entire
composition.
It's a good point though.
I hadn't thought of it in those
terms, but that's it exactly.
You got a call by the oboe and
then a repeat of that idea maybe
elaborated by the strings.
So here we are up here,
the solo oboe,
and then we are going to have
the response now by the strings,
so let's listen to that.
>
Here we go, strings.
Okay.
We're going to pause it here
just for a second.
Now something interesting
happens.
When we were dealing with
sonata-allegro form we said that
there were four functional types
and this really isn't just
limited to sonata-allegro form.
There are functional types in
all kinds of music.
When you go to a movie,
a cinema, a film for example,
oftentimes at the end of the
scene, they will have a
fade-out, and listen to the
fade-out music.
There's kind of transition
music in film music a lot of
times.
Then maybe we get a new scene
and it's very prominently
displayed--well,
maybe we get thematic music at
that particular point.
So this idea of theme and
transition,
even development,
can occur in all different
kinds of music in all different
kinds of context,
but just to review that idea:
we have thematic music,
we have transitional music,
we have developmental music,
and again it doesn't have to be
limited to sonata-allegro form.
We saw developmental music in a
section of a--of the fugue
called what?
Does anybody remember what we
called that section of the fugue
that was so developmental?
Thaddeus.
Student: The episode.
Prof: The episode,
so there we--in the episode of
the fugue we have developmental
activity and we get ending,
cadential, stuff virtually in
every kind of music so it's not
limited just to sonata-allegro
form.
But the question here is what
is Beethoven writing at this
particular point?
Here we are in theme and
variations but I think we're
referencing one of the four
functional types of music in
this next section.
So what functional type is it?
>
Okay.
So what was that that we just
heard?
What would you guess?
Daniel.
A transition.
Yeah, he's just taking us very
simply from point A to point B
>
and maybe just a little bit
idea of a cadence.
Transitions usually end with a
couple of final-sounding chords
there at the end,
so that's a transition and
we've moved and we've moved from
here >
, a major key.
What would you imagine we're
going to move to?
A minor key and it's probably,
again,
although we don't hear it--I
don't hear it--
we don't hear it,
it's probably going to be the
relative minor because it's just
simpler structurally to operate
that way.
So let's listen now to the next
variation here,
but something very interesting
happens.
He's referencing another form.
He's incorporating another form
in the composition as a
variation, so what is the other
form now?
>
Okay. Let's stop it right there.
So what form is he referencing?
Michael?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Got it right
today.
Okay.
Student: A fugue.
Prof: A fugue,
yeah, and we--in just one
hearing is--
was a little--it'd be hard to
really know what voices would
bring it in but I'll just tell
you.
Generally what he was doing
there was starting up on the top
>
, okay, and then <<plays
piano>>
and gradually coming down in
terms of range.
So it was soprano,
alto, tenor and then bass.
And the bass did something
interesting which sort of
reinforces a point we had the
other day.
The fugue subject that he's
working with,
>
which by the way--
So he's kind of varying that
melody number one,
>
kind of varying that melody,
but when it gets to the bass it
does something interesting.
>
Why is that interesting?
What process do we have at work
there that we talked about last
time with regard to fugue?
Does anybody remember that?
Daniel?
Student: Inversion.
Prof: Inversion,
and I don't think I made that
point clearly enough the other
day,
but any time you have
>
or you could have <<plays
piano>>
it's going up a minor third and
then down a second.
You could go down a minor third
and then up a second.
So you're just turning the
intervals and then kind of a
mirror image there.
So here Beethoven uses a little
bit of inversion.
So in the middle of this theme
and variation movement he
inserts a fugue,
and a fugue inserted inside
another form is called a fugato.
So here as the fourth,
I think fifth variation of this
last movement he inserts a
fugato.
We're going to listen to one
final variation here and we--at
this point we want to
concentrate on the duration of
the melody.
We were starting out
>
, one, two, one,
two, in that fashion.
What's Beethoven doing here?
>
Here we go.
Let's pause it there just for a
second.
So what's he done here to his
melody, to the duration within
his melody?
Hm?
It's now--can you express it?
If we were coming--
>
and now we're going
, what's he doing?
Student:
>
Prof: Well,
come on.
I just hear small,
little words out there.
I--somebody--let's choose
somebody who's pretty confident
and that person will yell it
out.
Marcos?
Student:
>
Prof: I'm sorry.
I didn't hear that.
Student:
>
Prof: That's the
psychological effect of
ritardando,
slowing it down,
giving you a sense you're
getting to the end,
but once again,
technically,
that's not exactly what he's
doing.
He's giving that effect by
doing something.
Thaddeus.
Student:
>
Prof: Right.
He's changing the note values.
He's simply doubling the note
values, and when we do that in
music we call that augmentation.
Sometime, when we get to Hector
Berlioz, we'll see diminution.
To give a sense of urgency to
the music, you can chop them all
in half.
Well, here he's getting toward
the end.
He wants this grand,
broad effect.
He's brought in the brasses.
It's show time so what does he
do?
He doubles all of the note
values in theme number one so
let's continue,
please.
>
Okay, and then he sort of fades
out and adds a little coda at
that point.
But that's the way we end the
Third Symphony,
the "Eroica Symphony"
of Beethoven.
So it's an interesting piece
because he's got a fugato in
there,
he's got sections that sound
like transition out of
sonata-allegro form,
and he's working with two
themes.
Questions about that before we
move on?
All right.
So let's put that behind us now
and go on to talk about
ostinato form.
Once again--we've been through
this many times--but what is an
ostinato?
Okay. I know it's embarrassing.
It's something that happens
again and again and again,
just sort of
obsessive-compulsive disorder
applied to music,
okay, obsessive-compulsive
disorder applied to music.
The most famous example of this
is probably the <<plays
piano>>
the Bolero of Maurice
Ravel,
so we've put that up on the
board here as our first
ostinato piece,
1928, a piece in the twentieth
century.
It's ostinato in every
way in the sense that the melody
keeps repeating over and over
again for fourteen minutes.
The rhythm <<plays
drum>> ,
that keeps going for fourteen
minutes and change,
depending on the tempo of the
conductor.
And when we did this,
remember, you guys were
providing the bass harmony
>
and that's all you do for
fourteen minutes and thirty
seconds.
So every aspect of
that--melody,
rhythm and harmony--is
controlled by this
ostinato procedure.
And then this example,
as mentioned,
from the twentieth century.
But the heyday of
ostinato form,
well, really,
in two periods in the history
of music: one,
in the Baroque period;
and two, right now.
Because when you start
listening to your pop music--
go out there and listen to
those basses and start charting
those basses and see how
repetitious they are.
When Frederick Evans brought in
that piece of 'N Sync or
whatever it was that he brought
in and I started listening to
that I thought:
"My God,
he's got a descending
tetrachord bass,
ostinato,
embedded in that."
Now I'm sure Frederick didn't
sit there scratching:
"Oh, yes,
there is my descending
tetrachord--
chromatic descending tetrachord
bass there,"
but it's in there.
It's embedded in so much of
this popular music and that's
kind of what we're going to
track here a little bit,
but we're going to start with
the Baroque.
So we can start with--who is
the best or the--yeah,
we could even say the best
composer of the Baroque.
Well, J.S. Bach,
so let's start with an organ
piece of Bach,
and we'll listen to an
ostinato bass.
Generally speaking in music,
when you get an ostinato
it's applied to the bass.
It sets up a repeating harmony
so that's what we've got here so
here is a passacaglia,
just a little bit of it,
by Bach.
>
So let's pause it there,
and you can see what he's doing
once he gets his bass in there,
and it's a typical eight-bar
pattern.
It's odd how many of these
ostinato basses are in
eight-bar units.
So it's an eight-bar pattern
here with Bach.
Then all he does is keep
throwing over top of that
different rhythmic patterns and
slightly different melodic
patterns as well,
but that bass
>
keeps churning away over and
over underneath in that piece
for what instrument,
by Bach?
Organ, big, powerful pipe
organ, that wonderful,
wonderful sound.
All right.
So that's an introduction to
the basso
ostinato,
the ostinato bass,
by Bach.
Let's turn to some music now of
Henry Purcell.
Henry Purcell was an English
composer working in London at
the end of the seventeenth
century.
He was employed by--it must
have been James the Second,
and then, I think,
William and Mary for a little
bit.
So he wrote for the court and
he also wrote for the theater.
And in one instance,
and it turned out to be his
most famous composition,
he wrote an opera for an
all-girls boarding school in the
London suburb of Chelsea.
I guess it's now part of
downtown London.
There's a famous soccer team,
Chelsea something.
I don't know.
You see them on TV.
So there is Henry Purcell out
at this all-girl boarding school
and annually they put on a
drama,
so it was kind of like the
senior class play and all of the
roles were sung by women except
in this case one role was sung
by a male and that was the role
of Aeneas.
So we've got the famous story
of Dido and Aeneas.
You've probably read it in
literature classes and you've
probably read parts of it in
Latin.
It's from Book IV and it used
to be in a really good
secondary-type education.
When you were doing Latin and
you've had maybe six or seven
years of Latin you would read
the--Virgil's Aeneid in
the original Latin.
Anybody do that in your--wow.
Holy shmoly.
Latin is making a serious
comeback here.
Because it's not easy.
It's not easy stuff.
It's traditional classical
Latin where the syntax is
radically different than
medieval Latin or any kind of
modern language.
Okay. Well, good for you guys.
So you know the story.
Somebody tell me the story then.
Michael, what's the story?
Student:
>
and Aeneas has to leave
Prof: Okay.
So Aeneas has to leave for
another country.
It happens to be what country?
Student: Rome.
Prof: Yeah.
He's got to follow his destiny
and go off and found the city of
Rome and, in the vernacular,
having ditched Dido back in
Carthage.
She's not happy about this.
She dies.
Depending upon the theatrical
version or the original,
she either stabs herself,
falls on a burning funeral pyre
or dies of a broken heart,
but this is opera so you know
that at the end of it the
soprano's got to die.
Right?
This is the way operas die.
Operas end--die, dead.
So anyway you could do
Violetta,
in Traviata--you could
do Tosca.
In Tosca--we've even
seen here the Liebestod
at the end of Wagner's
Tristan.
Isolde dies after singing the
Liebestod--expires
there--so it's a convention of
opera.
And in this particular opera we
have a famous aria.
It's called "Dido's
Lament" where she is
lamenting the fact that she has
been abandoned by Aeneas,
and it's interesting because
it's built on an ostinato
bass line and it's built on an
ostinato bass line that
descends,
and this is important because
it became a convention for
lamentation.
So this is the bass line for
"Dido's Lament"
here >
and it just keeps recycling
over and over and over again.
That's the ostinato.
And then up above that we have
the lamentation,
"When I am laid in earth,
may my wrongs create no trouble
in thy breast.
Remember me,
remember me,
but ah!
Forget my fate."
So that's what she's singing,
so let's listen to a bit of
this and before we do that we
have the term on the board up
there,
"ground bass."
All that is is the English term
for ostinato bass--
ground bass,
ostinato bass,
the same thing,
but it gives us the sense at
least that the bass grounds;
it kind of holds together.
It's the foundation for the
entire composition.
So let's listen and we'll start
with the ground bass and--and
then the singer will come in.
>
Okay. Let's stop it there.
So that's how this plays out
and that bass keeps cycling
through the duration of this
particular aria.
Listening to this recording
gives us the opportunity to
think about approaches to music.
This is a piece written at the
end of the seventeenth century
and actually in this particular
recording they're playing this
and singing in a way that would
be rather similar to the way the
would have done it in the
seventeenth century.
They have reproductions of
seventeenth-century instruments,
and the singer here is trying
to create a particular approach,
vocally, to the music.
So as we listen to this
recording one more time we're
going to hear just a little bit
more of it and then we're going
to ask you to compare this
recording to another recording.
This would be the kind of thing
that a reviewer would do,
so let's listen to a bit more
of this recording,
A we'll call it,
and then we'll move on.
>
All right.
Let's pause it there,
and now we're going to go on to
recording B.
So what's the difference here
in approach in terms of
orchestra--everything--voice,
and how does recording B differ
from recording A?
>
So maybe we'll pause it there.
What's your reaction to that?
How do those two differ?
Hands, please. Caroline.
Student:
>
Prof: Okay.
The first singer had a much
more youthful approach and you
could see that as an attempt to
maybe duplicate the performance
context of the original
performance in a high school--
a girls' school there in late
seventeenth-century London.
More specifically,
what about the quality of that
voice?
Any thoughts?
Roger.
Student:
>
Prof: Okay.
Now, so we have the two
recordings.
Which of the two had more
vibrato?
One or two?
Student: Two.
Prof: Two had a lot more
vibrato so that's really the big
difference here,
that one was a very
well-focused voice with very
little vibrato and maybe that's
what gave it this youthful
appeal.
It's almost like the voice of a
choir boy or a choir girl for
heaven's sakes,
a pre-adolescent child,
but intending to make it very
pure and very clean and very
well-focused.
The second
recording--what--that might be a
recording that you would expect
to hear--a performance you would
expect to hear where?
Maybe in a modern opera theater
or an opera hall,
a hall designed for opera where
they've got this huge expanse
that we have to fill.
What about the orchestra?
Frederick.
Student: It seems like
the second piece the bass line
was more tenor,
slightly higher ostinato
than the other one,
and it seemed like the
repetition was a little bit
higher--
Prof: You mean higher in
terms of pitch?
Student: Yes.
Prof: Frederick,
you have a very good ear.
Actually, that's true.
There's--I don't want to get
into this, but the first
recording is pitched in F-sharp,
in the old Baroque tuning.
They're trying really to be so
authentic.
Pitch in the Baroque era was
actually lower than it is today.
We know that because there are
tuning forks that survived from
that period.
They got labeled on it A--you
play that A and it turns out to
be our G-sharp,
so aficionados of this
particular repertoire when they
go to perform Baroque music
they're going to use
reproductions of authentic
instruments,
they're going to use
non-vibrato singing,
and they're going to use the
lower pitch.
I didn't plan on getting into
that but since you picked up on
it, good for you.
No, we don't have to get into
that,
and to be honest with you,
the only reason I remembered
that was I went to duplicate--
before coming in here today,
I went to duplicate those
pitches on the piano so I'd be
up to speed with this and I
realized geez,
that I'd have to do this in
F-sharp and that's going to
require some quick transposition
up here because I can do it
quickly in G with only two flats
but F-sharp,
how many sharps that I've got
there,
and I had to figure all of this
out,
so--but that is going on there.
That's an interesting
development, yeah.
Anything else?
What about the tempo of the
two?
Size of the orchestra always
determines to some degree the
tempo.
Oscar.
Student: Slower.
Prof: Yeah.
The second recording was much
slower.
You--I was intentionally trying
to beat it up here to--and it
was a very labored beat pattern.
It was much slower because they
had many more instruments,
a lot more people playing,
axiomatic--
the more people you have,
the longer it takes for sound
to clear,
the slower your tempo will go
unless you have a maniacally
dictatorial type of conductor
that will really push you.
So it leads to--the more
people, the slower the tempo is
going to go.
So what we have here is a
reproduction--
an attempt to reproduce an
authentic seventeenth-century
performance as opposed to a
modern performance,
big sound, metropolitan opera
type of sound.
All right. Let's move on here.
One of the interesting aspect
of this--
I discovered this driving down
Whitney Avenue--
this is true--driving down
Whitney Avenue one day,
I must have been fishing for
ninety-one point five on my FM
dial and suddenly had a seizure
or something and I didn't quite
make it,
and I was listening to Elton
John.
Okay, listening to Elton John,
and what did I hear but the
craziest thing.
What I heard was this text:
It's sad, it's sad,
it's a sad, sad situation,
and then I heard
>.
I said, "Whoa.
Wait a minute there.
That's the Purcell bass line.
Elton John has stolen the
Purcell bass line.
Arrest that man!"
No.
We don't do this because,
as we say, these bass lines are
in the common domain.
As we have said before,
we can't sue anybody for the
theft of a bass line and indeed
it was all over the place in the
Baroque.
This is a type of--it became a
kind of musical icon.
Any time an audience would hear
>
they would think death or bad
news, and actually,
we still do today.
Isn't "Hit the Road,
Jack" based on that same
kind of ostinato bass?
But in the Baroque you could go
back to Monteverdi's
"Lamento della Ninfa."
You could go to Bach's cantata,
"Weinen,
Klagen, Sorgen,
Zagen,"
to whine,
kvetch, and you could go to the
"Crucifixus"
in the Bach B Minor Mass.
What could be more painful or
dispiriting than a crucifixion?
So this was a moniker.
It was a kind of emblem of
lamentation, whether it's in
Purcell, whether it's in Bach or
whether it's in Elton John.
So then Elton John was to take
this and he used it not at the
beginning of this piece,
"Sorry is the
Saddest"--
or "Sorry is the Hardest
Word to Say."
He didn't use it at the
beginning.
He used it in the chorus.
So here we are in the chorus of
Elton John's--I think it's
"Sorry is the Saddest Thing
to Say" or something like
that.
>
And then he goes on with the
next verse.
Okay.
So that's just one example of
the use of that particular
ostinato bass.
We actually call that a lament
bass and many--and Mozart even
did it.
He wrote a violin sonata on the
occasion of his mother's death
in E minor and he has that thing
just going down and descending.
Basically, it's this descending
tetrachord chord here that gets
filled in chromatically.
All right.
So we've got that as an
ostinato bass.
What's the most famous
ostinato bass of all
time, Baroque or modern?
The Pachelbel bass.
Okay?
And we've got this thing called
the "Pachelbel Canon."
Do you have the Xerox for today?
What's the "Pachelbel
Canon"?
Well, we've worked a little bit
with this.
I think it was Listening
Exercise eight,
I believe, early on in the
course where we were trying to
have you focus on changing
harmonies,
and these harmonies are just
generated by this repeating bass
line.
There's an irony with the
"Pachelbel Canon"
and that is that you never hear
the canon in the "Pachelbel
Canon."
Why is that the case?
It's because if you look he's
got these three canonic lines--
the three staves up above--all
in the same register,
and when people record this
they always do it with the same
instrument,
usually just with a violin,
so we have the violins up
above,
three violins all playing in
the same register.
You can't pick out the canon.
It just sounds like this
unfolding jumble.
It's a very beautiful jumble
but it's indistinctive in that
sense.
Maybe if they orchestrated
oboe, flute and clarinet,
maybe we could hear the canon
better.
What we hear,
of course, grinding away
underneath is the
ostinato bass so let's
listen to just a bit of this.
And I was struck the other day
when I went back and listened to
this recording on your CDs.
They have put in this something
that's actually Pachelbel didn't
write.
When this starts out they just
start with a <<plays
piano>>.
What's that?
>
It's a descending major scale
so they've just said,
"All right.
Here's your basic tonality.
Here's your tonal grid or
whatever."
So let's listen to the bass
start out.
Then we'll have this descending
scale that Pachelbel didn't
write and then his canon will
start, and you can see how this
works here.
I've indicated A.
A gets repeated as B comes in
and so on.
It's pretty straightforward how
the canon operates.
>
Okay. Here comes the scale now.
And now the canon starts:
A one, <<music
playing>>
the second voice comes in,
>
the first voice goes on to
present something new,
B.
>
So we'll pause it here now.
We're going to pause it here,
and it goes about four minutes.
It is very beautiful.
It's lovely--lovely,
lovely, lovely,
lovely.
But you know this bass line.
Right?
>
Okay. So there's our D.
Let's all sing it together.
Ready, sing.
>
Okay.
So once you get that in your
ear, you have a sense,
oh, it's really in there and
that you may have heard that
many different times before.
Now lots of people made use of
the "Pachelbel Canon"
and I know of at least three
and maybe four that I've put up
on the board up there and you
may know of more.
Marcos sent me a YouTube clip
of a comedian.
Maybe you guys have seen this.
What was the comedian's name
who was made sort of so sick of
the "Pachelbel Canon"
because every piece he picks up
has got the bass line of the
"Pachelbel Canon"
in it?
Who--what comedian was that?
It doesn't matter.
Okay. So those are my four.
Anybody else know where else
they show up?
All right.
Well, let's review,
but keep in the--oh,
Thaddeus, good.
Student: Britney Spears.
Prof: Britney Spears has
the "Pachelbel Canon"?
What a time to be alive. Wow.
>
All right.
Thaddeus, go get that for me.
I need this one.
This is gold.
Thank you very much,
but so--but check it.
For example,
one of the students,
Daniel in here,
sent me--or gave me--and we
talked about it,
and let's go to that one.
The--it's--He said this may be
a knockoff of the
"Pachelbel Canon."
It's called the "Taco Bell
Canon."
So let's see if the
"Pachelbel Canon"
is in fact embedded in the
"Taco Bell Canon"
here.
>
Okay.
So is that the Pachelbel bass?
>
Is that the pattern you were
singing?
Yes or no?
How many think yes?
Raise your right hand.
How many think no?
Raise your left hand.
No, it ain't the
"Pachelbel Canon."
Is it an ostinato bass?
Yes, it's an ostinato
bass.
So we could keep playing with
that.
I could play you Coolio,
Blues Traveler,
Vitamin C.
Just for laughs let's do
You've--and I'm sorry about
this but it's too good to pass
up.
Okay. So out you go.
Thanks for your attention.
>
Appropriately enough,
it's in the key of C,
Vitamin C, see.
>